a witchy woman with a walking house is
waiting at the climax of the witcher
season 2. if you need help figuring out
what's going on here don't worry you're
not alone
the second season of the witcher isn't
so much about its titular anti-hero but
rather about cirilla the princess of
sintra or siri as she is more often
called much of the second season focuses
on siri trying to learn more about
herself and to lineage while different
factions hunt for her this includes
groups such as the mages the elves and
the nilf guardians however individuals
such as the volath mare aka the
deathless mother a mysterious fire mage
named rhians and yennefer are also
seeking siri it's revealed in this
season that siri is distantly related to
the ancient race of elves in the final
episode family the mage is red finds
francesca's groups of elves in the woods
outside sintra and tells them siri is
henna care or of elder blood her elder
blood offers some explanation as to why
siri has such incredible untapped powers
it also leads francesca to believe that
siri could be the one prophesized to be
the elven oracle ethelene we heard bits
of ethelene's prophecy drawing season 1
when siri falls into a trance while
fighting people trying to capture her in
season 2 we see siri read the entirety
of ethelene's prophecy from a book at
the temple of melatelli before that
triss helps her undergo deep guided
meditation in which they learn that siri
is descended from lara doran which makes
her daughter of chaos all of the female
descendants of lara have been imbued
with magical abilities as she was a
powerful elven sorceress
in a game-changing twist the mysterious
emperor emea of nilfgaard dubbed the
white flame is revealed to be siri's
father the last time we saw her father
previously called dooney he had been
saved by geralt from death at the hands
of siri's mother pavetta's family
including queen kalanthi of sintra this
story called a question of price in the
book the last wish explains how geralt
came to be the adoptive father of siri
through the law of surprise after siri
was born dooney and pavetta supposedly
drowned in a storm and their daughter
was raised by her grandmother kalanthi
in season 2 dooney aka emperor amir is
very much alive although the episode
ends on a cliffhanger and offers no
other details as to what the white flame
has been up to the past couple of
decades however his arrival explains why
nilfgaard sacked sintra and has been on
a bloody mission to find siri it also
sheds light on why nilfgaard's leaders
knew about her genealogical history and
powers even before she did amir has a
long bloody history in the books so
expect the ruthless nilfgaardian ruler
to become the main antagonist in future
seasons of the witcher
season 2 of the witcher finally delves
more into the history of the continent
and its people particularly the elves
who inhabited the lands long before the
humans came during the conjunction of
the spheres though they have a long
history filled with magic and prophecies
steeped in belief and hope the elves are
the underdogs of the witcher when humans
came to the continent the entire race of
elves was nearly wiped out as humans
considered them lesser beings throughout
the second season francesca explains
bits and pieces of the elves history and
their motivations in working with the
humans of nilfgaard at the end of the
day francesca and her people want
justice not revenge as both yennefer and
siri are descended from elves and imbued
with magical abilities it won't be a
surprise that future seasons of the
witcher draw deeper connections between
elves and the ability to wield the magic
of chaos while some might consider
francesca and the elves red herring this
season it's clear the blood of the elves
and siri are more deeply intertwined
than first meets the eye
at the end of season one yennefer uses
fire magic to turn the tide against
nilfgaard's forces at the battle of
sodom hill and saved the day however
this forbidden magical method comes with
a price yennefer loses her ability to
wield chaos throughout season 2 of the
witcher yennefer desperately tries to
find a cure for her missing magic during
her journey across the continent she
joins up with fringilla and francesca
together the three mages eventually
encounter the home of volith mare the
deathless mother who has been trapped in
her roving hut for centuries bowleth
mayor makes dangerous packs with the
three women to do her bidding feeding on
their pain and fear while friendzilla
and francesca make a desperate bid to
ensure their own power and safety
yennefer refuses to let voleth mare take
siri in the final episode the magical us
yennefer saves siri by becoming the next
vessel for volath mare siri then
teleports herself yennefer and geralt to
another sphere of the universe letting
voleth mare free and brings them all
back to cair moren when they return
yennefer discovers her magic has
returned the moment as a turning point
for yennefer as much of the first two
seasons see her looking out for only
herself and being driven by her own
motivations however beneath those
selfish seeming actions it's her deep
desire to be part of a family in the
witcher season 2 she finally finds one
with siri and geralt
us three will help each other
what is destined cannot be avoided
beau let's mayor the deathless mother
was actually a bit of a red herring in
the witcher season 2. while the
appearance of the deathless mother and
her straw hurt on chicken legs connects
with the crohn's of the witcher 3 wild
hunt and the mythic tale of baba yaga in
the second season of the witcher boleth
mare becomes a means to an end
ultimately the last episode reveals that
she was just using francesca frangilla
yennefer and siri to get back to her
real home in another sphere of the
universe siri in particular is a
powerful tool for beaulieu mayor in the
final episode of season two as the
deathless mother possesses the
princess's body to wreak havoc on care
moren through siri vodaf mare kills
three sleeping witches and destroys the
sacred medallion tree revealing a black
obsidian monolith encased inside
volathmer then uses series primal scream
to shatter the monolith and open a
portal to another sphere unleashing
mutated monsters on the
[Music]
me what she witchers to you
she is the future
the battle is brutal and bloody as
massive mutated basilisks swarm the
witches killing several before order is
finally restored one scene shows geralt
channeling his inner harry potter by
slaying a basilisk by shoving his sword
through the creature's mouth in the end
volley femare is back where she belongs
after a season of corrupting the pain
fear and magic of some of the key
players of the witcher
in this season mage and former lover of
yennefer israel is a traveling historian
studying the continent's monoliths he's
also secretly acting under the guidance
of stregabor the manipulative mage and
member of the brotherhood introduced in
season one through israel's travels we
discover more about the history of the
continent its monsters and what the
monoliths have to do with it all it is
shredding gerald to travel to the
massive crack in the earth caused by
series scream to try to find out where
all these new monsters are coming from
with them we learn that the monoliths
are gateways to the other spheres of the
universe and that those spheres contain
all sorts of dangerous creatures finally
through israel geralt learns theory has
the power to topple these monoliths
which can open portals to the other
spheres towards the end of the season
it's dred visits the famous kodringer
and fenn a detective agency and law firm
to try to learn what a witcher a
monolith and mysterious girl have to do
with nilfgaard he learns about siri's
elder blood and her connection to the
elven sorceress lara doran in their
research the detectives decipher that
when the elves fought the humans
centuries before they didn't just build
a weapon to destroy their enemy they
built a warrior these revelations may
offer hints as to why francesca and the
elves are so keen to get to siri
in the season 2 finale siri geralt and
yennefer portal to another sphere and
encounter the riders of the wild hunt
these undead warriors tell siri to join
them explaining to her that she belongs
with them and even calling her the
starry-eyed daughter of chaos in the
live-action series not much is said
about the wild hunt in season 1 and 2
beyond some brief mentions which makes
it interesting that they finally show up
in the last episode beyond that their
appearance also adds another faction who
is after the prophesized child of
surprise in the witcher the riders of
the wild hunt are essentially a version
of the four horsemen of the apocalypse
important of doom and destruction the
people of the continent believe the wild
hunts are undead beings who signaled the
arrival of war and death
well there's the race
the wild hunt
yes
the wild hunts who are actually and l
elves are also known as the race of
mohawk a group that invades other
spheres to wreak havoc and capture
slaves since their motivations are death
and destruction through invasion the
arrival of the wild hunt sets up another
key antagonist in the future seasons of
the witcher should they manage to get
serious powers and bloodline in their
hands the wild hunt could truly become a
force to be reckoned with
don't skip the end credits of the
witcher season 2 or you'll miss the
first teaser trailer for the witcher
blood origin the prequel series is set
over 1 000 years before the witcher and
follows the events leading to the
conjunction of the spheres which merges
the worlds of humans elves and monsters
into one the series is also set to
explore the creation of the first
witcher this teaser focuses on elves who
band together to journey across the
continent training with one another and
also shows an early conflict with some
heavily armed men
no more details have been released for
the prequel series beyond this 2022
arrival date although the teasers
footage also shows brief shots of what
looks like the elves world before humans
arrived this includes a shot of a mage
holding the staff that makes up the
series logo and another elven sorceress
and for regalia and makeup the witcher
season 2 especially the ending adds tons
of details about the history of the
continent and its people however fans
can surely expect the witcher blood
origin to delve even deeper into the
history of this fantasy world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the witcher are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you